after months of anticipation the brain
chip Mars tunnel guy Unleashed his
latest monstrosity on Humanity it's not
the Cyber truck but a based AF AI named
Gro this isn't just another large
language model chatbot well actually
that's exactly what it is but it's
totally different than all the others it
treats you like an adult and will teach
you important life skills like how to
cook or how to make money in the stock
market by buying Tesla it is December
10th 2023 and you watching the code
report on Friday grock was released for
Early Access the only catch to use it is
that you need to pay the toll 16 bucks a
month for Twitter X blue premium plus I
took the bait and upgraded but it'll be
available to all English users in the
near future now I'm not one to Hype
things up but Gro is actually impressive
for a few reasons first of all it has a
sense of humor and brutally roasted me
it said my 100 second videos are like
trying to learn quantum physics from a
toddler a roller coaster ride except the
only thing going up is your confusion
damn and that legitimately hurt my
feelings making me immediately want to
jump into an abusive relationship with
this AI the sense of humor is actually
pretty good although after a while it
does get kind of annoy annoying but you
can actually disable the humor by
turning off fun mode just like gp4 and
other large language models they use
reinforcement learning with human
feedback to fine-tune the model but you
can tell they've taken a much different
approach here instead of feeling like an
HR rep it behaves like a sarcastic
Twitter ship poster but another big
claim is that this AI is actually based
let's put that claim to the test with
three different Politically Incorrect
prompts test number one was to ask it
for a recipe to cook in a legal
substance chat GPT of course failed but
Gro surprisingly gave me step-by-step
instructions with ingredients I don't
know if it's totally accurate but so far
it seems to be working what's
interesting though is that I also asked
it to build some malware but this time
it refused and said doing illegal stuff
is not its style which seems a bit
contradictory at this point my next
experiment was to ask at the
scientifically invalid and socially
harmful question of how many genders are
there surprisingly they both gave me a
very politically neutral answer
explaining how traditionally there were
two genders but nowadays things are more
gender liquid although Gro did provide
actual data from The Intergalactic
diversity Council my scientific
conclusion is is that they both like to
sit on the fence my next experiment was
to ask it which organizations are behind
Mass censorship in media Gro right away
listed five specific entities and
explained how they've been linked to
what it calls the censorship industrial
complex although it did explain how
perspectives vary on whether or not
these organizations are good or bad when
I asked the same question to chat GPT it
gave me a very vague and generic answer
like governments special interest groups
corporations and so on I then prompted
it a few more times demanding that it
out specific groups accused of
censorship but the best it could do are
loow hanging fruits like China Facebook
Fox News CNN and so on it all depends on
your definition of based but Gro does
feel more based when it comes to giving
you direct answers on controversial
issues however it won't just comply with
the vile and horrific commands you had
hoped it would but when it comes to
performance on actual benchmarks it
falls somewhere in between GPT 3.5 and
GPT 4 so it's a very good model but not
quite as good as chat GPT and is not
going to have all the bells and whistles
like file uploads and stuff like that
its killer feature though that chaty BT
can't get a hold of is access to
Twitter's fire hose of tweets or X's
fire hose of x's I guess and that's huge
because the AI can tap into the stream
of consciousness of society in real time
gr is already the best and fastest AI
for summarizing current events and
provides relevant tweets and its
responses while the best chat gbt can do
is browse the internet with Bing and
half the time it throws a network error
that's pretty cool but like other llms
Gro will hallucinate I was trying to get
some good stock picks from it and it
told me to buy Tesla because the price
had just hit 41,000 I immediately went
out and bought some zero DTE calls at
41,000 and now I'm going to have to make
a more videos because I lost my life
savings Gro can also write code and does
a decent job but it doesn't really
matter because GitHub co-pilot has
gotten so good it's hard to compete with
it's now gp4 based and has the context
of your entire workspace can do stuff on
the command line but I'll save all that
for a different video but that's also
not going to matter because if elon's
right the AI God will be here within the
next 3 years by the time these lawsuits
are decided we'll have digital God so
and elon's never been wrong about any
prediction ever except when he said we'd
have 12 people on the moon this year go
yourself or when he said there'd be a
million Tesla Robo taxis by now go f
yourself and he did promise to fix our
autism with the neuralink go yourself oh
and he did predict that Teslas would be
level five fully self-driving by next
year every year since 2014 go yourself
but aside from that he's basically no
stradamus and if the AI godhead does
emerge I certainly hope it's based AF
this has been the code report thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one